bergeron support si pire qu'il ya deux
ans encore et encore on est quoi pied
2010 est à peu près un pied et demi à
peu près et puis en demie plus boc 2017
mais samantha tout les jours 3 400
points soit 4 1 pouces et ses supposés
de monter 10 15 centimes ait pas plus
que ça jusqu'à là demain et vous vous
êtes dit cette année je vais prendre les
moyens
mais pour ce que j'aime ma propriété
également très sain c'est le watergate
watergate qui fait sens c'est fabriqué
par des québécois victorine plus l'eau
va arriver plus avoir monté ces derniers
vont gonfler
tu voyais ont commencé à aller en
ramenant la baule et sont gonflés pas
mal plus que ça comme celle au seul
exposé dans l'idée vous dites moi je
dois être plus fort que cette eau là
c'est dur d'être forclos l'a6 est
peut-être plus franc que nous l'idée
c'est de investir à long terme sur 20
ans si tu eu 40 pour une pièce diffusée
sur 21 ça fait 2000 2100 bien nommé même
pas parce que voulait pas partir vous
c'est un gars qui ne l'a pas eu de la
chasse
j'ai tous les équipements jeu les
bandits la maison aurait planté l'essai
d'arabes spel qui est rentré 442 royal
de tailler un site et j'ai une partie
héliose partie de ma vie c'est et
comment tu vas y que je te faire dire
qu'en me tombait à 2717 en avant et puis
c'est plus tard propriété comme le
gouvernement il ya fait il ya pris
possession la cadre de la carte de la
propriété vue nous ont mis dehors
c'est plus attrayant prix de taï do khac
on a été évalué à 28 28 % de dommages
nous on met notre taille donne mais en
même temps monsieur bergeon vous qu'on
panique les gens les autres les autres
québécois qui sont pas inonder se disent
ils sont une ode et à chaque année pas
qu'il ait changement climatique savoir
venir tout le temps il faut qu'on trouve
des solutions
chapeau monsieur legault a dit après
cent mille pièces je vous donner de
l'argent mais pour déménager je dis pas
que ça va vous touche et peut-être avec
ça vous allez être capable de rire
même temps avez vous de vivre ça chaque
année non moins l'année prochaine si ça
monte pas il faut mettre la propriété en
vente
puis je vais traiter complètement alors
les ballons vont aller avec la propriété
le type qui est des personnages en coupe
ou pique il acheta ils vont à savoir qui
de sécurité qui peut être installé fait
venir les goys l'instant si ça coûte
1000 pièces un examen simple alves un
symbole apposé un exemple ça lui coûtait
1000 pièces puis à son bord d'anouilh à
qu'est ce qu'il veut c'est tout
après 2000 où elle s'était coupé a5 1
pouces nous allons monter jusqu ici l
hôtel de lahontan d'abord d'éviter
combien dommage j'avais eu combien
d'argent tout et partout 145 me combien
vous avez reçue du gouvernement
80 les bâtisses a fait au moins 34 1
pour ne jamais eu saut alors se faire
dire il ya quelqu'un de la paroisse et
ce qui est bien placé et a envoyé un
commentaire assez comique vous avez vous
l'a voulu avoir des bords de l'eau est
rare et vous avec
et que serait pas sans toi je suis pour
que je vous réponde à ça moi j'ose hop
jose pour répondre parce que ces gens-là
yeux puis et tropézien mois justin est
hyper m'écraser chipie le dessus mais
les gens au québec sont au sec qui
disent ce thème rapaces bâtir s'y
produisent exactement soit mais qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ça les courtiers
passe à l'époque chaleur son solo son
choix ce qui est pas facile c'est que
kim on change quand vous dites ce
n'était pas arrivé
oui pour neudorf faune qui veut pas
arrêter le carbone fait que gabon allons
donner le temps pour les etats-unis qui
avaient tous pu tout 28 puits de charbon
qui verrait la pleine capacité qui
viennent à toutes les autres pays du
charbon parce qu'il ça apporte que c'est
qu'il ya que c'est que ça engage
est-ce qu'ils travaillent contre ça la
pollution non serré verges
pensez-vous vous allez pouvoir vous
chante se pose problème on veut vendre
on va vendre à la perte sévère je
remercie puis en tout cas votre
barrières on regarde ça marche